resident evil village is nearly here
which also means big fun spooky times
with a big beautiful cast of
sexy people and the return of our
faceless but
still sexy protagonist ethan winters
making village something of a direct
sequel to seven despite
that it isn't actually called resi8 but
still has the roman numeral branding
anyways it's been a few years since
ethan was trudging through the louisiana
swamps to the now
snowy depths of a gothic european
village
and honestly remembering what went down
is a little fuzzy as a lot
happened in seven from the baker family
to a mind controlling bioweapon
to two endings with only one being
cannon and the return
of handsome mick hamsterson chris
redfield with the exception of chris
redfields resident evil 7 is almost
entirely a standalone in the series too
so no need to freshen up on the entire
franchise but if you're interested we
have a dense
and detailed complete timeline just for
you
link in the description below let's
recap what went down in the baker house
all those years ago to prep for our
journey to village
so strap into the wacky train to
resident evil town with me
your conductor and tour guide kurt
indovina
previously on resident evil
okay it's 2017 ethan winters is on the
search for his
missing wife mia who went m.i.a
in 2014 after going on a work trip to
babysit
she was presumed dead however ethan gets
a tip from her out of nowhere to come
and find her in the swamps of
louisiana it isn't long though until
ethan finds himself in an old
riggity-ass abandoned farmhouse and
finds mia no longer
m.i.a but alive and held captive in a
dungeon below the house
while traversing the house a mysterious
woman named zoe
gives ethan a ring-a-ding-ding and gives
him the one to get the [ __ ] out of there
through the attic
oh but unfortunately mia has
uh changed a little over the past couple
of years
she goes berserk and poor little ethan
ends up having to kill mia after she
cuts his hand off
with a chainsaw and just as he makes his
escape he's knocked out by none other
than
jack daddy baker welcome to the family
song
ethan wakes up to a quaint dinner with a
lovely family
how nice well at least ethan's hand has
been stapled back on
ethan breaks free and then doci does his
way around a famously cryptic and
confused resident evil house with
arbitrary puzzles
locked doors with emblems and statues
holding valuable items that otherwise
trigger booby traps
anyway ethan gets another call from his
secret admirer zoe who happens to be
the baker family daughter speaking of
the bakers they have regenerative
powers something ethan learns quite
intimately after a little run-in
with jack
what's in the louisiana water and where
can i get some
on second thought i'll pass what the
[ __ ]
in another one of her trademark phone
calls zoe reveals that mia
is alive and infected with the same
regenerative virus
as the baker clam ethan turns into a
fetch quest boy for zoe and goes to
gather the necessary ingredients to
create a serum that'll cure
both zoe and mia of the regenerative
infection thing
while ethan's again dosey doing around
and busy killing baker mama marguerite
the baker's son lucas captures both mia
and
zoe in order to rescue them ethan has to
go through one of lucas's saw like
obstacle courses
but just as ethan is about to get that
serum bam big bad
daddy jack slams into scene leaving
ethan no choice but to use it
on jack and kill him permanently leaving
ethan
only one serum to use and having to
choose between zoe
and mia what the hell are we gonna do
now okay so this is where
it gets a little weird with the timeline
between resident evil 7 and village
while there's only two paths which lead
to only slightly different outcomes
only one of the endings seems canonical
to village
so let's just get the non-canon one out
of the way first
i'm sorry i really am so let's say ethan
chooses zoe mia is left behind with a
broken heart even though
ethan promises to send help on this path
zoe and ethan hop on a boat
and she reveals to him that the bakers
first became infected after mia
walked into their lives with a little
girl named evelyn
three years back which is when mia went
all mia
on their way they passed by a giant
wrecked tanker ship
and in this moment zoe is killed and
giant sludge tentacles knock ethan out
while unconscious ethan has a vision of
chit chatting with a sane
jack baker who is communicating with him
somehow telepathically anyway
the now sane jack tells ethan that the
entire baker family has been
under evelynn's mind control which is
what drove the baker family
mad to begin with and now ethan's gotta
put evelyn down
in order to end all of this free my
family
please it then switches to mia's
perspective who finds herself on the
wrecked ship
and trying to rescue ethan how romantic
when ethan comes too mia is there
however she goes all possess mode again
and struggles to grapple with ethan's
choosing of zoe home wrecker baker
mia's changing is of course a result of
evelynn's mind control and
once again ethan is forced to kill her
okay now let's rewind in this other
timeline ethan chooses mia because
duh it's his wife and stuff and clearly
he's been through some [ __ ]
already that he can forgive her for
cutting his hand off
cue ethan getting knocked out
conversation with jack mia rescues ethan
bamboo but in this path mia manages to
lock herself in the ship
as evelyn takes control giving ethan the
chance to escape
and not kill mia again
alright so as it turns out mia has been
working with an international criminal
organization called
the connections who specialize in
bioweapons
her job was to be a caretaker for evelyn
a bioengineered weapon referred to
as the type evelyn can infect people
with a psychotropic mold
that allows her to mind control them and
that whole regenerative thing
is actually just a side effect while on
the boat a hurricane rolled in
hitting the ship hard which gave evelyn
a window of opportunity to take matters
into her own hands infecting the entire
ship
with her moldy gooey powers that is
until the ship is destroyed
and washes on land in the wreckage jack
baker
finds mia and evelyn and takes them into
his home
now considering evelyn is a
bioengineered person in all she wants
nothing more than family of her own
so using her powers she takes over the
baker family
driving them to insanity also gotcha
granny baker has actually been evelyn
the whole time ethan and mia cook up a
toxin to kill the [ __ ] once and for all
and the old bag is obviously like
yo nah she turns into a giant face
apparently that's what you do when
you're you got
super moldy gooey powers and like all
resident evil's before it a conveniently
placed weapon is dropped into ethan's
hands
and he kills grandma i mean evelyn for
good
that special weapon fell from the
heavens above i mean mr
mick hamsterson redfield who flew in on
a helicopter
donned with a blue umbrella logo which
is like the good version
of the umbrella corporation formed to
instead combat bioterrorism
instead of make it in the case ethan
chose zoe ethan ends up leaving on the
helicopter with only mia's belongings
which he tosses off
if you chose this ending then well your
choice doesn't actually matter
because mia's in resident evil village
and ethan and her have a kid
then chris just shows up and kills her
anyway right in the trailer so
she dies again supposedly
that poor woman she literally exists to
get killed over
and over and over again she's like
resident evil's punching bag
she'll probably be in resident and yet
still we have no idea if anything i just
went over
will have anything to do with village at
all
there are so many questions to be
answered why is chris redfield a total
dick now
why is ethan and mia's kid so damn
important and will ethan get stepped on
may 7th couldn't come soon enough all
right
that's it thanks for coming along this
wild ride again
i'm your travel guide kurt devino you
can bug me on twitter at curt underscore
in dovina now that we're done with the
baker family and sludge people on with
werewolves big vampire ladies
this suave looking fella and this van
helsing looking son of a [ __ ]
let's get it
[Music]
[Music]
you